شخص ما بمعنى هو صاحب هذا المصطلح بمعنى
ده فيه بمعنى عذبه عذبه قلت له طبعا يعني
اضربه اضربه بحيث انه جسمه يدفع هاي هي كل
القصه يعني
بمعنى اشبيعه ضربا حتى
جسمه يصبح حارا يعني بس حتى في ليالي
احتفالات في الخارج ليالي راس السنه
بعض الجنود يعني ياتون الى ساحات
المعتقل ليتسلو
لبعضنا
يعني دائما يمكن كل سنه يعني خاصه في فتره
راس السنه طبعا
الطاقم اللي بيكون مناوب داخل السجن
يحمل وزر مناوبته داخل السجن للسجناء
نفسهم عنده يعني
كذا وكذا احتنعتونا نحتفل مع اهلينا ومع
عائلاتنا براز السنه يعني
فيصبوا الجامعه غضبيه عن المساجين يعني
بتسلوا بحفلات تعذيب وتعرف راس السنه
بتكون من ابرد ايام يعني
وبهذه الملابس المهترئه واللي لا تقي من
البرد نهائيا يعني وهذا حدث العذاب قد
تستمر ساعات يعني
ايضا بحفله من حفله من حفلات العزاء هاي
ممكن ان يكونوا الضحيه مثلا
عدد من السجناء يعني يقتلون يقتلون يموتون
يعني يموتون اما بردا او تعذيبا